agora saiu e aí ela tem que assistir o
coral tudo com vocês só aceitarão
triunfal e alegre que eu fiz agora é
porque eu estou feliz não é não porque
estou aqui pra reclamar da operadora sem
fronteiras sem fronteiras é o [ __ ]
você pega um trem azul você vai tomando
eu tinha me recusado a falar sobre esse
tema um tempo de tentar atrair que eu
achava isso não todo mundo falando da
tim é tão fanático não falar que eu
falar que não vou ou não vou mas ainda
mais velho não vai mandar mais vai pôr
todo dia eu estou usando a internet
daqui porque porque estou sempre
conectado às redes sociais twitter
instagram facebook começou uma pessoa de
internet tenho que passar o dia inteiro
na internet ou procurar o operador que
nas propagandas me dizem que fazem
milagres e todo dia recebo essa mensagem
com o infinity web só navegação
ilimitada você atingir o consumo diário
informado regulamento sobre velocidade
pode ser reduzido um dia seguinte me diz
aonde molesta uma coisa é ilimitada e
tem um limite de consumo diário porte e
eu sei que a gente é bobo e tal mas
também é preciso ver se mantém é preciso
baixar tanto a gente foi pintar chamados
brasil é de burra nem isso profícuo
ai meu deus do céu que tenham mais raiva
é que a tinta ensinava nas horas que
você não precisa ter pressa nas horas
que você não precisa agora na hora que
você precisa o sinal cai df makelele pbs
mas é assim mais um pouquinho porque
vamos combinar a maioria dos usuários
você você que tem o tino seu celular
você vamos combinar que a gente usa tim
para mandar mensagem para usar a
internet porque a ligação é somente
enfrentar fala pra mim não é edson a
essa necessidade todo estrondosos
estrondosos de sinal que dá raiva que na
hora que precisa no momento aquele
momento que precisa não tem ontem passou
o dia todo no final eu deixei meu
celular sem mexer um pouco não sabe eu
lembrei que tinha celular e finalmente
no celular da vítima mensagem da minha
mãe assim me liga
vamos combinar que me liga e um amigo é
um
me liga do seu irmão é pois me ligue do
papa é outra coisa agora me liga da mãe
aí eu pego o celular ligar meu deus do
céu estrupa quando chegar em casa já deu
sinal a depor e não tem porque não basta
ensinar o segundo tempo que faltar
quando você precisa sempre tem um que
chega e fala assim como a dar um troco
do chifre querido mas não dá pra trocar
o chip sabe porquê porque o cliente 23
via torpedos para qualquer operadora por
apenas 50 centavos por dia e navega na
internet também por apenas 50 centavos
por dia e tem mais o cliente fitch pré
pode fazer ligações para qualquer tim
por um pequeno valor fixo por chamada
aproveite cansei de ouvir isso eu vou
pedir esta especial eles conseguem fazer
algum tipo de macumba que não deixa a
gente mudar de operadora sério é sério
já ouviu alguém falou num novidade não
odeia pau e ninguém muda todo mundo
reclama da tim mas continua na tinha um
time feitiço que não deixa de sair com
luciano huck faz propaganda da tim que
tem um raio não é isso que eu tenho
raiva que é concorrente ela sempre quer
se atingir sempre que tiver muita
atenção com o latim bota sei lá cinco
centavos a ligação é concorrente cop4
sentar é sempre assim ela vai abaixando
é outra baixa um centavos abaixo o que
acho que está muito melhor que ela se
uma baixa para 5 outra baixa para 4 é
outra baixa para 4 o trabalho para 3 se
a outra baixa para tereza os
trabalhadores se a outra baixa para 1 é
outra saída e também da rua é de graça
que a minha de gaza pega meu chip bom é
isso que é tão rápido aqui além dela ser
ruim ela vai embora este ano as outras
não foram cortadas ligação que a
atividade mesmo quando ver quando o cara
é tornar o amor você é a coisa mais
linda maravilhosa tudo nesse mundo é o
que eu disse que você é linda e
maravilhosa am e disse você é tudo nesse
mundo é o último aparelho aparelho é tua
mãe aquela vagabunda vontade de mandar
esse aqui empacado [ __ ] aí me
chamaram na paraíba mandou pagar do
[ __ ] acabou a rotura acabou quantas
mães já ligaram por fim da caixa de
mensagens em que o telefone está ligado
chega em casa leva pisa culpa de quem do
filho não na tinta um vídeo onde é esse
você concorda com o que eu falei é só
clicar aqui e gostei que eu vou
agradecer muito você tem algum caso pra
contar que aconteceu com vocês operadora
de celular comenta que macho se você
está
no facebook o desgosto compartilhe com
alguns amigos
usuários da tim está no twitter tá aí pq
isso ajuda muito e falou que eu vou lhe
trocamos mensagens da tim porque apenas
50 centavos por dia né
já tinha o cardinal shiita vivo aí